dodger lineup here for the second game
in this three-game series looks like
this with mookie betts to lead it off
that's riding a nine-game hitting streak
this one over to bets
he is drilled to left-center field
mookie bets
with a lead off home run
on the second pitch of the game he
drills his 14th of the year he got the
barrel to that one easily wilkie bentz
has been an absolute delight as taylor
moves up to second muncie's aboard and
aj pollock comes up the hit potluck one
for six in last night's game scored a
pair of runs rojas the second baseman up
the middle behind the bag pollock lifts
that out to shallow right center john
jay is there and now here is where
clayton kershaw has been almost
untouchable this season opponents one
for 14 with runners in scoring position
coming inside with a 1-1 it's left over
the plate driven the other way bets goes
back on it shy of the track he's got it
speaking of hernandez here he is
wearing number 21 tonight like
players from puerto rico are on this
roberto clemente on a 3-2 pitch
hernandez turns on it lifts it to deep
left field varsity shows going back on
roberto clemente day wearing 21
hernandez hits a home run
a special night for hernandez just
became magical
touches the 21 points to the sky
with a very meaningful home run
loaded up nobody on the hitter is carson
kelly one-o to carson kelly
on the ground right to seeger takes a
bad hop
they'll get one and the diamondbacks are
on the board as roja scores
two balls and a strike on john jay
mathison is at third var shows at second
jay gets this one up in the air
lukey betts has got a big arm
matheson's at third and here he comes
the throw is into third and we are tied
at two
so far still at second base two outs now
for la castro who rounded out to lead
off the ball game for the diamondbacks
that's headed for left center and that
one gets
down here comes dalton le castro will
head for third tim lecastro is in there
with an rbi triple and it's 3-2
diamondbacks
dodgers threatening down to run in the
fourth but they've got him loaded up and
nobody out
bounced to short ahmed to rojas won
they'll hang on to it dodgers tie the
game
first and third one gone lux tying the
game with the feeders choice ground out
and up comes kiki hernandez who hit his
fourth home run of the year his first
time up
blasted by third base hit to left field
and the dodgers retake the lead on
hernandez's second run driven in tonight
still looking for more of those
[Applause]
gets one there
gets his second k tonight as varsho
takes a seat he's retired sixth straight
gate here carson kelly stands in the
1-2
kelly swings and
pops it foul and bellinger playing at
first base tonight makes the catch about
three steps in foul territory and
another good inning for kershaw he's at
first with one out for nick ahmed nick
is walking struck
ahmed reaches out and pokes it down the
line that's a fair ball the castro's on
the run and so is ahmed they're going to
send le castro home the throw from bets
is not in time ahmed heads for third and
we are tied at four
all tied up at four one and oh on
christian walker three hitters oh for
three tonight here comes gradual
bouncing ball to short seeger across his
body for one locks to first a double
play
he gets will smith to the plate trying
to drive in the go ahead run
got him junior garris strands two just
like that go ahead running scoring
position
went with it and got him looking it
wasn't outside i know that's the
argument there around home plate but
that ball was perfect
he struck him out
ferguson wins the battle
up the varsity
chopper right side
gavin lux
ends the inning hernandez is aboard with
one out
dalton varshall in left field
back to the bag at first two down for
seeger
swinging and i missed hernandez off with
a pitch but crichton gets a big
strikeout on the curveball
pitch leaders in the third
sharp ground ball base hit center field
and the dodgers take a 5-4 lead as
taylor drives home corey seeger
extra important second run is in scoring
position now
pollock rips it to left center field
base hit bringing home the all-important
second run here in the 10th he's in
there safely with his third hit of the
night in a 6-4 dodger lead arizona down
to its last strike
6-4 bottom of the 10th
3-2 from trinin
ripped to first on a bounce there's
bellinger to the bag and the dodgers
have taken both games in extras